[Music]
all right well let's play the alakan
um we've switched a little bit from the
caro to the alakin
and this is the first time we got
somebody playing e5 which is great so
knight t5 is the move of course
the alakan is like the ultimate opening
which gets very bad rap
but at the level of 13 1400 is
is as good as any other opening if you
know how to play i mean it's going to
probably get us a better position
now this is the classic hyper modern
opening you're literally sending your
knight around the block
trying to get his pawns to move as far
as possible to overextend his center
i've explained that a million times i'm
not going to go into that again and
there we go now c5 in and of itself is
not a bad move this is a line
but you guys can already see that he is
straining
his resources these both of these pawns
are actually quite weak
this pawn is going to be a backward pawn
and this knight
is actually an outpost which he can
certainly target by developing his
knight to c3
but now we can make things go boom
and how can we make things go boom which
is a quite a good idea because he's
there's several ways to look at this
position he's played d4 which is a good
move
defending his pawns but you can see an
iqp position in the works here you can
see
an isolated queen pond position in the
works because if these pawns disappear
you have a pawn on d4 whoops you have a
pawn on d4 that's remaining
and that pawn's blockaded by the knight
so in the event
that we have a bunch of trades
we're gonna be on the good side of the
iqp because we're gonna have this square
control but he goes correctly bishop c4
okay so we have several options here for
how we choose to respond to this move
and
there's a creative option here which
might not occur to people immediately i
mean you guys might be thinking of e6 or
maybe c6
both of which are actually perfectly
fine moves
but what else can we do to temporarily
defend the knight
okay bishop b6 is not great
because although it develops a bishop it
does so at the expense of the other
bishop
and it allows a move like queen b3 but
we can actually take a pawn
and i'll flesh that out after the game
we can actually take one of the fun
doesn't matter which one
because now the queen defends the knight
and now once again after he takes back
which he will both of these pawns are
once again very weak
and so now when we play e6 we've opened
up an attack on this pawn
and this pawn is no longer easy to
defend so you guys can see like
very clearly the punishment
that he is now facing for pushing his
pawns out too early
this is okay for white if he plays this
very well
but we're facing him with serious
problems
i mean he could take our knight okay so
he just decides to sort of part ways
with the pawn which is
a reasonable take on the position but
now we're up upon we've got a nice night
and we've got a great position and
that's it eight moves in where we have
we have the advantage not bad the only
big
well big the only issue that we face is
that we're a little bit passive right we
we're going to have a hard time
developing this bishop
and this pawn on e5 is actually quite
annoying it's controlling a lot of space
it's
it's slightly severing the communication
between our two two flanks so we'll have
to be
cautious about that okay bishop g5 how
should we respond to this
how should we respond to this
and we should go by the principle of the
least awkward move
now in such situations you need to weigh
the pros and cons right f6
allows e takes f6 and after g takes f6 i
mean your king side is going to be
destroyed
don't like it queen d7 is awkward
because
then we're definitely not going to
develop the bishop there's just
something about queen d7 that looks very
awkward
so let's go bishop estab nothing wrong
with the retreating move
when you know under the right
circumstances
and the alkyne is an opening where you
just have to embrace
living on the last two fl to ranks
sometimes which is not an inherently bad
thing okay so h4 he's trying to play
aggressively
but you know this bishop we don't have
to play a lot of people would play h6
here we don't have to
why do we need to play h6 let him be the
one to take
let's not waste our time um instead
let's focus on developing asap and
developing the best possible way
um castling is great yeah let's castle
and just because he's played h4 doesn't
mean that he's going to checkmate us in
like four moves
he can't play h5 here then he drops the
bishop
and if he takes our bishop then we can
take with a knight and offer up a queen
trade which is good for us because we're
up upon
uh yes we're probably going to actually
yeah we're going to fianchetto
and we're going to do that right now the
other great thing about fianchettoing is
is that we support our knight which then
becomes a serious outpost
so c6 would bury this bishop a little
bit further
i think that the intention behind c6 is
good which is to support this knight
more but we're going to do that by
solving another problem at the same time
which is the problem of our
light squared bishop and
okay g4 so
he's trying to attack with his pawns but
that's kind of like trying to you know
it's like trying to break down a
you know the what i don't know
offense with a noodle that you take to
the pool
because he just doesn't have enough
resources to break this down and now he
blunders
a bishop which i warned you guys about
yeah he drops a piece and
yeah now the seams have completely come
off here
yeah so the queen is defending the
bishop which is why he's blunted it
now we can take the rook here but the
fact of the matter is and this is
something which
doesn't come naturally to a lot of
players which is fine
because it shouldn't come naturally you
should you should prioritize material
and
yeah bishop takes h1 is maybe the best
move but the fact is
if we take his nine we had something
like this yesterday
um this actually might be better than
taking his rook because we eliminate the
annoying knight
we attack the spawn you guys should be
able to see how this bishop is
worth its weight in gold so by not
displacing it we're
basically going right after his throat
here
this is just more practical right we're
still up a full piece that's fine
okay
no people blunder like this but okay so
now let's start mopping up the pawns
queen takes e5 check
now you shouldn't be just i don't think
you should be disparaging of the
blunders let's develop our knight let's
complete it we could also take this pawn
but
no need to be too greedy let's finish
our development instead
um he was already in trouble
by the time that we played bishop b7 his
position was almost lost at this point
so this isn't the sort of thing oh he
played a tribe and therefore he lost
um he was already lost he made the big
mistakes previously
okay what should we do now what should
we do now
so in the spirit of knight c6 it's the
same type of mode
right we should just patiently bring our
pieces into the game
yeah rook d8 for sure let's bring the
bring the heavy guns in and orchestrate
some
some pins here very simple rook to open
files right
exactly and the other rook by the way we
can think about
being creative here you will say well
rook feat that doesn't seem like a good
move it's just staring at the pawn but a
good way
to uh open up a file for this rook is to
play f5 of course
which again might cause some
uncertainty in you because you might
well doesn't i take on g5 and open up a
file for his rook
but remember with with everything is
relative on the board
and a single rook is not going to cause
problems on this pawn because it's
already defended by everything you're up
a piece
his position is is you know melting
and falling apart in the first place so
the fact that we've opened one file for
him and the fact that our king happens
to be on that file
it looks a little bit scary but you have
to see the bigger picture and understand
well are there actual pieces
that could cause problems and which are
the squares that actually are the
problematic squares
i don't know if i just if i made any
sense there okay so g5
is is a good movie he's trying to keep
it closed so what should we do now
we can still activate the stroke i'll
give you guys a hint and the next move
is pretty natural
so the next move we can play is yeah we
can target this rook over here
good look at this everybody in unison
and when we push a pawn like this we see
that there is a square that is left
behind
and this square could be occupied by the
rooks we could now send our rook forward
and although the f file remains closed
uh the fifth rank has been opened and
his pawns are
just going to be vacuumed up by the rook
okay rook c3 so he's potentially going
after our knight he's
semi-threatening to take it but if we
really want to check madame asap
so i wonder if people will see this move
this this is actually definitely the
best move
what should and it's not rook f5 it's
not queen takes g5
it's essentially
to yeah f3 now what is the mechanism
behind this mobile first of all let's
deal with
why is knight takes f3 impossible
because that opens up the pin against
the queen the x-ray
and so we can just play bishop takes f3
and win another piece
but what we are really preparing here is
the move queen to h2 so that's how i saw
this move
i also recognize that there's a pattern
of putting a pawn on a third rank
and checkmating the king of the first
rank because that's like a makeshift
backrank
weakness right we're just controlling
these two squares of the pawn
so this pathway to h2 and the funny
thing is we can just close our eyes just
bring our queen there we don't even have
to take his rook we'll take it if he
defends but
we don't have to take it immediately
whoa desert pagel with a five gifted man
thank you desert pigle appreciate it
that's that's lovely
okay knight takes f3
now this move um
ought not to cause any panic
what should we do what is the very yeah
i just take with the [ __ ] don't even
bother with the checks just take with
the bishop just take with the bishop and
that's it
and literally this is just crushing
okay so malachine
strikes again and
that's why i'm always railing against i
mean i like tier lists and stuff and i
like
talking about openings but most openings
within you know the overton
what is that what is it called i'm
referencing the political overton window
um and by that i mean like non-e4 h5
openings can be made to work
sorry i had a complete blank uh they can
be made to work
um at this level
and that is not a you know uh
backdoor way for me of like trying to
laugh at
people at this level it's just because
um
i think people have the wrong sense
sometimes of openings like the algon
they think well at the grand master
level the alakan is not played because
it's horrible
no in fact it is played at the grand
master level kicaro played it
when he first become gm there are
several grand master practitioners of
the alakan
who make it work and the same goes for a
lot of openings which
have you know dubious reputations so
it's a question of gradations it's a
question of slight advantages this
we're not talking here about horrible
openings that have been refuted
okay
yeah well i think the french is like a
meme by now okay so e4 and
f6 well the alakan is rare it's
definitely rare
e5 knight d5 the philidor's philidor is
actually
experiencing a resurgence it's very
solid opening
okay so e4 knight d5 c4
knight p6 now the best move here is to
play d4
and to occupy the center but to do it in
a measured way
and black plays d6 he takes d6 and
there are two main lines there's e takes
d6 and c takes d6 but the move that i
recommend
for people who are interested in
starting the algon is c takes d6
because this teaches you to play with an
imbalance pawn structure imbalance
of course because now white has a queen
side majority and black has
essentially king side majority and
black develops very naturally here this
bishop is going to have a hard time
getting out on this diagonal so you find
keto it
very nice i mean natural development you
know like knight c6
and the plan emerges naturally from this
position you're going to put pressure on
white's two pawns
um okay so that's really all there is to
it and there's a lot of theory
um it looks like a dragon but
yes but of course it's much more
peaceful because you've tasseled short
and
neither side is is is going to get
checkmated in the next five move
um yes so it's very hard to play at like
1100
and there's two main reasons for that i
think right
what makes a position like this hard to
play for black the first thing is of
course that we're a little bit cramped
and it's natural to find it hard to play
as i said on two three ranks
because it makes you uncomfortable and
you gotta know you gotta be accurate
right when you're very cramped you
cannot afford to make too many mistakes
you're just going to get
pushed off the board the second thing is
you've got to know how to react to a lot
of different things
when you're playing an opening like e4
e5 you have a very stable center
the position is relatively symmetrical
so
there aren't that many things your
opponent could do that would really
unsettle you and
think of the alakin is um
sorry let's come back to this position
white can make a lot of different
unexpected moves he can go c5 and attack
this knight
and he can go d5 and attack that night
and
the more experienced you are the less
these kinds of moves intimidate you and
the more you know how to think about
them like here
if you're experienced you'll see ah well
d5 attacks tonight but what square does
it leave behind
so let's practice that kind of thinking
what square is the pawn no longer
controlling where can we put the knight
yeah 95 not too hard right 100 bits
thank you marie
and okay now we can think okay so how is
the position changed well now the
bishop's diagonal is really good
and this pawn on c4 is a little bit of a
weak link so maybe we could go queen c7
but dynamically adapting to these
changes
is hard and it takes some experience and
there's nothing wrong with
telling yourself it's too early for me
to play these positions i'm going to get
some more experience first that's this
you know or you can try okay so c5
knight d5
d46 this is actually okay
but i think he should probably i don't
really know what white is supposed to do
here to be completely honest
i actually think that he should probably
take
and then go like knight f3 or something
just to vote but we've got a nice
position we've got a good night here
okay so he goes bishop c4 takes takes
and e6 is correct and
i think he played correctly actually but
um in this position white should just
develop
and you know what would be a very
interesting idea here
again on the concept of recognizing
patterns
um this part what makes this spawn
annoying is that it's
controlling the f6 square which makes it
hard for the knight to return
would the night want to return well
maybe it's a different phone what can i
do here to set up a tactic
what could i do here to set up a tactic
thank you furious lasers the friend
d3 threatening as
helen of troy would tell you threatening
a greek gift lexi and anything for the
250
threatening agree gift well you might
say this is not scary black and go h6
but
white will go bishop c2 and why we'll
try to build a little battery here
so black has to be very precise here
okay
uh but after bishop g5 bishop e7 i mean
h4 is okay i think that
he really went downhill with this move
g4 is is
essentially a decisive mistake i think
if he
dials it back and just castles white is
much much worse black's got an amazing
position but the game goes on
and y can continue to play but of course
we understand why he went g4
and i think i'm gonna i'm gonna make a
pronouncement which
might raise some eyebrows for once i
think pawn storms are overrated
in my experience when people are taught
to attack
they are first and foremost taught that
most attacks start with pawn storms
you have the stereotypical like h4 g4 g5
h5 g6 but wait a second like that
already takes six moves
and most attacks how dare i in most
attacks
um you know wrong formulation
you often don't have that kind of time
so
peace attacking with pieces to me is
the more important skill to start with
if you're teaching someone
basic attacking chess because pawns are
only going to get you this
so far you and again don't take this too
far pawn storms are
extremely common but you want to
understand what what is the purpose of
them generally the purpose is to open up
the king
so that the pieces can have an easier
time
um attacking but you can you also use
the pieces for that that's what
sacrifices exist so anyways
here clearly he doesn't have the the uh
horsepower literally to do anything with
these pawns
and when he starts upon strum like this
he's weakening
all these squares around his king and of
course now the game is over
oh i was going to explain one thing
which is that
yeah but the king's indian is an
exception that's not an opening which is
commonly
seen at you know the 13 1400 level
and i don't mean
uh storms are overrated in the sense
that they're uncommon i didn't say that
i said that when you're learning
attacking chess you should not assume
that all attacks
feature a pawn storm um and i think some
people kind of think that
bishop e6 here is bad because it blocks
this bishop
it blocks the epon which is a bit
committal and i i think this move is
very annoying because it puts more
pressure
and it attacks b7 thank you rizzo pay
thank you so much
and yeah this gets a little bit annoying
okay so that's basically that um any
questions about this game guys
could you encounter well yeah that would
be the i think that would be the uh
only thing you could do on move 11 or 12
why is bishop take 65 to win upon bad
let's see oh yeah so
great question uh and an amazing catch
that definitely deserves to sub oh
you're already subbed
um on mar gate sans
asks so bishop d5 exists and
the point is after ed bishop e7 the
queen's attention is divided
and you have to give upon and i do
believe that white should have probably
gone for this
but if you think about this position now
right white's got h4 that's weakening
white hasn't developed the knight and
white has this very weak pawn on e5 so
we could pile up on this one we could go
knight c6
and what development move would enable
us to further
essentially highlight all of the
weaknesses in white's
position and that would of course be
bishop g4
which threatens all of the white's
position starts to collapse here
but yeah queen b4 you've got to be
careful about because white is queen d2
and this is the advice i've shared about
forks right
the the three types of ways to defend
against checks you can move the king
you can interpose and you got to check
all of the interpositions you got to
make sure
that the interposing piece is not also
defending the second thing that's being
forked
queen d2 in wet is fine okay
bishop e6 here would blunder the b7 pawn
so you wouldn't want to do that
all right
[Music]